une alliance pour les municipales 2020 à
voisins le bretonneux
c'est ce que souhaite olivier afonso et
thierry gastaud de conseillers
municipaux d'opposition de la commune
c'est vraiment une grande déception à
sentiment de gâchis pour tout vous dire
nous avons eu un maire qui est vice
président de l'agglo qui conseillère
départementale et donc sur les sujets
majeurs de notre ville rien n'a évolué
la remise qui est ça fait plus de dix
ans je crois que c'est en stand by la
circulation rien n'a été fait sur les
six dernières années pour cette liste
qui se veut sans étiquette les priorités
sont fixées notamment ceux qui
concernent l'aménagement de la ville
si on mobilise nos partenaires
l'agglomération et le département et
qu'on s'inspire de tous les dossiers
tous les projets d'urbanisme qui ont été
rédigées les années précédentes les
solutions existent il faut investir
massivement faut être ambitieux mais la
solution n'existait pas du bricolage en
espérant sur les mêmes voies
qu'actuellement faire passer 30%
d'habitants supplémentaires c'est pas
possible
jointe par téléphone la maire sortante
de voisins-le-bretonneux élu depuis 2015
alexandra rosetti se dit surprise par
cette alliance entre deux représentants
de l'opposition entendait quand albert a
fait plus fort mais bon il reste quand
même deux autres que l'action politique
bienvenus un clin ils ont pas fusionner
leurs débats population dont on voit
donc de m'interroge en brisant quelques
leurs griffes et leur volonté lui de
prendre en a bien une candidate pas
candidate oui candidats alexandra
rosetti qui a donc annoncé sur notre
antenne qu'elle se représenterait pour
les élections municipales en 2020 le
scrutin se déroulera le week end du 15
et 22 mars